I think that a lot of the initial, so there's a thing I don't know what the term is. I call it
like a card quality issue. So I would say do not use any type of debit card issued by a bank
because I think I said it in a video or something that I posted a group.
When you go and do that initial charge, it's coming from overseas. It's not coming from the
United States. So if you're here and you're doing a charge wherever it's coming from,
it could send a block. Now, they're so fast that as soon as they feel that, done, suspicious payment.
They don't give you that. It's done so fast that you don't get like that. Today I got one on my
phone for my AAH ref's charge. So every five or six months, I get a thing and they're like,
hey, are you approving this? And I'm thinking like, yeah, no shit, it's a recurring payment.
But for whatever reason, every five or six months, my credit card company makes sure
that I approved it. But it's because it's coming from out of country.
But with Google, it happens so fast that you get flagged right away and then there's nobody to talk
to because there's nobody answering those phones. So if you have a debit card, those have a lot
because that's protecting your cash right now. So they're going to have a more scrutiny on the
security features with it. So that's one thing I've told a couple of students, like I wouldn't use
your debit card.